Hi, I am back with Art and now I'd like
to get into commits and commit messages.
So commits are one of the main reasons
we use Git as a version control system
so you can make these
incremental changes and
you can see what changed every
time you make a commit, and
a very important part of
this is the commit message.
So why is the formatting of
the commit message so important?
>> I think that,
well formatted commit messages.
I find most important reasons to get
going because as you go through digging
through people's code or your own code
trying to figure out what's wrong
especially when you're looking for
a bug.
But somebody just want to know why
a line of code is the way that it is.
>> Yeah.
>> The first thing you're going to do is
go and get blamed.
Awesome tool.
And it's going to show you the committer
but also the commit message.
And if that message is just like added
stuff, it gives you no context for
why the code changed,
why it's there in the first place.
And that's super important.
It's super important for you as you
maintain your code down the line.
It's super important for people that
follow after you in maintain your code.
And so, it's funny, I definitely
when I look at candidates and
when I dig through their GitHub I check
out to see sort of how thorough and
well they communicate-
>> Yeah.
>> in their commit message.
It's really important.